[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily derek shum's
appeal for the murder of george floyd
might hinge on possible jury misconduct
how showman's case could be similar
to convicted wipe killer scott petersons
they're very similar in terms of what
the allegations
are the trial begins for a former
florida sheriff's deputy accused of
planting drugs on unsuspecting motorists
the shocking promise his defense made
in openings you will hear from zachary
wester
and georgia's citizens arrest law is
overhauled after the shooting death of a
mod arboret
one of the three defendants are now
expected to stand trial plus
an ohio man admits on the stand at
killing his roommate and burning the
body
but tells the jury it was in
self-defense any normal person that had
a gun pointing at him is going to go get
one
law on crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
germain misconduct is one reason derek
chovin is arguing for a new trial in the
death of george floyd
law encrimes anjanet levy spoke with an
attorney who says the chauvin juror
issue
is similar to one in another high
profile case anjanette
yeah brian this potential issue with
juror brandon mitchell just came up in
the last week or so there are questions
about whether or not he answered his
juror questionnaire truthfully
and it's a similar issue to one that's
going on with a juror right now
in scott peterson's case so many of us
by the time we walked into the
liberation room
um we were we were ready for for um
for a guilty verdict a week after
chauvin trial juror brandon mitchell
granted interviews a photo of him
wearing a t-shirt marked get your knee
off our necks came to light
mitchell told the minneapolis star
tribune the photo was taken last august
at a martin luther king jr commemoration
in washington d.c
where george floyd's family spoke
briefly mitchell told the newspaper he
answered no on his questionnaire to two
questions
one asking whether he or someone close
to him participated in demonstrations
against police brutality in minneapolis
a second asked whether a juror or
someone close to them participated in
protests about police brutality
defense attorney mark garagos sees
similarities to the scott peterson case
they're very similar in terms of what
the allegations are
garrigus represented peterson at his
trial for the deaths of his wife lacey
and unborn son connor in 2002.
peterson was sentenced to death
questions have arisen about juror
rachelle nice in that case
in the peterson case that particular
juror
on the questionnaire did not answer a
question
correctly now claims she didn't know
what a lawsuit was
niece had been the victim of domestic
violence while she was pregnant
and a hearing will be held to determine
whether peterson will get a new trial
based in part on the issue with niece
peterson supporters describe niece as a
stealth juror
someone who comes in with an agenda you
want to make sure you don't have anybody
who seems too eager to get on
but it's really tricky because these
stealth jurors tend to know
what to say to get on they tend to
moderate or temper their answers
they know to say they should be fair and
impartial jury consultant
alan turkheimer has written a blog about
mitchell and doesn't necessarily see him
as a stealth juror
but mark garrigus says there could be
other issues with mitchell
the questionnaire and jury selection if
the prosecution knew
that's misconduct if the defense didn't
and missed it
that's a problem uh if in fact there was
a
something on the questionnaire that
wasn't true that's the problem
so there's a lot of investigation that
needs to be done
an investigation of this potential issue
is likely what is going on right now
now derek chovin's attorney eric nelson
has requested a hearing
uh from judge cahill on this potential
issue
of durham misconduct and right now it's
just a potential issue we don't know if
there was misconduct
and a spokesperson for the minnesota
attorney general's office told me that
they would have no comment
on juror number 52 and that is brandon
mitchell
brian thanks angel joining us today is
criminal defense attorney adam conta and
terry austin
adam so far as angenette said we gotta
look a little bit more but so far i
don't see a problem with mitchell's
answer
i see a very weak and narrow question by
the attorneys because mitchell
protested voter rights in dc according
to him so he would be right to say no in
the question after those other two
questions right
well sure but the shirt he was wearing i
mean it says
it specifically references it seems to
reference showman's conduct
i still don't think it's a an issue
that's going to overturn
and get officer shove in a new trial i
just don't i don't see that happening
i mean this wasn't a heated uh uh
jury deliberation situation where he was
the deciding factor and convinced other
people
i mean you essentially heard from the
get-go that 11 people went in there
ready to convict
in 30 seconds um but let them do their
due diligence i think ultimately this is
going to be
a prosecutor that didn't know about it
in the defense who didn't do their due
diligence on checking up on it
i agree no terry mitchell is pretty
forthcoming with his feelings about the
concept
of black lives matter and still the
defense kept him do you think mitchell's
a stealth juror i don't think he's a
stealth juror i mean
frankly he was pretty obvious about his
potential
as a juror because he did say he
believes that
black lives matter do matter and that
you know
for a fact he said that he thinks that
all people should be
treated equally so i think the defense
realized and understood that he has that
position
there should be an investigation and i
think it is a claim that defense can
make
but i agree i don't think they are going
to prevail in this matter because
the issue came up they talked about it
and the t-shirt at the demonstration
really had very little to do directly
with black lives matter and had
more to do with martin luther king so
you know it's an issue but i don't think
it'll be appealed
now angela what is the status of the
juror issue in the scott peterson case
well actually uh an evidentiary hearing
is going to be held
about rachelle niece and she you
probably remember her she was very
colorful very flamboyant
after that trial very outspoken and mark
garrigus said she was actually writing
letters
to scott peterson at san quentin that's
part of the appeal and there is a
deadline this week for some filing of
documents
and the california supreme court said
that there needed to be a new penalty
phase based on some issues with the
trial
and that happened last year but now it's
possible
that this evidentiary hearing about the
juror could lead to an entire new trial
in the guilt phase
thanks for that and now for another top
legal story let's turn to terry austin
a police officer in new york city is
being hailed as a hero
for rescuing a little girl who was shot
this weekend in times square
the nypd says 31 year old farah khan
muhammad is wanted for
shooting three people after an argument
with his brother on saturday
three bystanders were wounded including
a four-year-old girl
out toy shopping with her parents newly
released
body cam video shows the moment officer
alyssa vogel
heard a child was injured she jumped
into action
scooping the girl up wrapping a
tourniquet around her leg
and taking her to an ambulance
oh
oh
quick thinking about new york's finest
still ahead of law and crime daily
the three men accused of killing a mud
arbory get a trial date
but first a former florida cop is on
trial accused of framing unsuspecting
drivers
of carrying drugs opening statements are
just after the break
[Music]
welcome back in florida a former
sheriff's deputy is on trial
accused of planting drugs on
unsuspecting innocent people
26 year old zachary wester started
working in law enforcement
in 2015 for the liberty county sheriff's
office he resigned nine months later
but on the very same day western was
hired by the jackson county sheriff's
office
the same office where his father led the
department's drug enforcement effort
prosecutors say they noticed
discrepancies between his reports and
body camera footage
according to the state western would ask
to search a person's car
during routine traffic stops and then
place white packets containing
meth unlawfully sending them to jail
you'll hear some of them like miss odom
ask for some kind of testing i mean
right there in the moment you'll see it
on the video
we'll ask for if there's any chance or
possibility to get dna testing on the
item
fingerprints some of them even ask to
provide a drug test right they're
roadside
and that's not what patrol deputies do
but you're going to hear that
on the video and just like miss odom the
defendant does not he makes a choice
to not document those things in his
reports but you will see them on the
videos
you're going to hear that during the
investigation of this case
the state and the foreign department of
law enforcement
did that to the extent we could and
you're going to hear
testimony in a few days about that and
whether or not
that was able to really show much it's
up to you to decide
during this case what value to place on
it but you will hear
that not one of those victims
fingerprints are found on those baggies
the defense however pointed the finger
at investigators for a slow
investigation
which they say proves their client's
innocence
let's talk about the search of the
troll card that mr wester was using
you heard the state say that they
believe that it's going to show
around july and mid mid-july late july
early august
is when they recommend fdle take over
the investigation of this case
and you're going to hear from the case
agent
miss chase she went and she gathered up
all kinds of evidence she's all these
reports everything from
you know the sheriff's office from the
state attorney's office getting
everything she could about all these
cases looking into everything
why didn't she or why didn't fdle
search his car they had taken over the
investigation at that point
that car sat there for four to five
weeks
before it was searched back with us to
break down the alleged drug planting cop
is criminal defense attorney adam konta
and terry austin terry the prosecution
really hasn't given a motive
for why wester would plant these drugs
do you think one is even needed here
with all the video evidence though
it's not needed but it's always a good
idea to have a motive you want the jury
to hang on to something and to
understand
why the defendant is actually doing this
i mean if they have to think about it
and perhaps there'll be more evidence
later down the line
maybe he just wanted to have more
arrests and so he was planning all of
these drugs
or maybe we do know that his father was
in the police force
so perhaps he wanted to make sure that
he was doing as good a job as his
family did as his father before him so
we'll see what happens but yes it's a
good idea to have a motive even if you
don't need it
absolutely now adam um i can hear the
defense attorney in the opening
statements but i'm not sure how much
of a defense is here do you see a
defense in this case
or is this just a long plea allocation
where wester
could face up to 20 years uh
i don't know i mean i i watched some of
this trial earlier today
and i think the defense attorney is
actually doing a good job i think he's a
competent defense attorney
um but the facts are the facts and what
they're gonna say
is well you don't exactly see on the
video so you don't know for sure
and that's doubt that's what they're
gonna go with i think but my god brian
this guy is accused of doing this to a
hundred people
at least and that's just the ones he's
accused of who knows how many he hasn't
been caught for doing
he one woman had his ki had her kids
taken away because of this
i mean this is an important trial this
should be on the front page of papers
across the country one bad cop can cause
so much damage in a community
and this is a prime example this should
be getting just as much attention as the
george floyd case
and it sickens me uh to my core to see
that this is happening
but the flip side of that he's caught
he's getting tried
and hopefully there'll be a stiff
punishment to follow i would agree and
uh
i would agree and follow those
sentiments with you adam thank you
coming up on law on crime daily an ohio
man accused of murdering dismembering
and then burning his roommate
takes the stand plus why amon arbor's
accused killers
will be seeing the inside of two
different courtrooms we will tell you
how soon on the other side of this break
we're back a judge has now set the trial
date for the three defendants in the
amman arborete case
gregory and travis mcmichael are facing
nine charges including malus murder for
the shooting death of a mod arboret last
february
a third man william rhodey bryan is
charged with boxing arbory in
while filming the incident they're now
set to stand trial together
this october i told him stop stop stop
till he hit me i had nothing to do
a federal grand jury indicted the three
men last month for interference with
rights
and attempted kidnapping both when
michaels are facing federal charges
of using guns to inflict violence
they're scheduled to appear in federal
court for the first time
on tuesday the guy turns and comes at
him
and they start wrestling the travis
shoes and around the damn chest he had
the guy was trying to take the shotgun
away from him in state court defense
attorneys for the men are asking to
disqualify the special prosecutor
appointed
force the state to reveal any deals made
with its witnesses
and are objecting to jailhouse calls
from the defendant coming into trial
the defendants are due back in court for
a motions hearing this wednesday
let's bring in criminal defense attorney
adam konta and co-host terry austin
discuss the upcoming trial
now terry the governor of uh georgia
governor kemp is replacing and repealing
the 1863 citizens arrest law
after the death of a mont arbory what
are your thoughts on that move
you know i think it's a great move brian
the bystanders can no longer
make an arrest in georgia if a crime is
committed in their presence
and i think that is just the right
initiative to take
and apparently it passed in the georgia
house and senate
by overwhelming votes so i think they're
moving in the right direction there are
some who actually said
that this was an old obviously 18th
century law that was passed because they
wanted to
see if they could lynch and they did
actually escape
slaves so i think it's a great idea and
i think that
it you know the family has actually said
that it's a great the mother said it was
a great birthday present
for ahmad aubry who just had a uh would
have had a birthday this past weekend
now out of the defense is trying to keep
out jailhouse
calls from the defendants what are your
thoughts on what could be there in terms
of incriminating information
i mean i don't know uh every time
anytime i hear there's jailhouse calls
that are getting admitted
i'm nervous uh there's really no way
that i know to really keep them out i
mean they're your client
who said them on a line that they know
is recorded
that's a pretty difficult uh bar to
overcome so if they figure out a way to
keep out jailhouse calls i would love to
know it
because i think we could all use it uh
but yeah it's never
it's never something that makes you feel
good when a prosecutor says oh by the
way we're gonna be putting in some
jailhouse calls
yeah they may go to intent they might go
to state of mind at the time but they're
never a good thing for the defense
and i agree i don't think they're going
to come out thanks adam and terry when
we come back
an ohio man accused of murdering his
roommate takes the stand
the shocking allegations michael dixon
is now admitting to and why he says it
was all in self-defense
next
[Music]
welcome back an ohio man on trial for
allegedly killing his roommate
and burning his body to hide the
evidence took the stand in his own
defense
michael dixon is charged with murdering
dismembering and then burning the
remains of his roommate
jim whitaker on the stand dixon admitted
to killing whitaker but says it was in
self-defense
dixon is also charged with sexually
assaulting his 18 year old daughter
dixon told the jury he was snorting meth
with whitaker on july 4th last year
dixon says whitaker got his gun and told
dixon his daughter couldn't leave with
him
that's when dixon says he went
downstairs to get his own gun
when i got back to the top of the steps
i could see the top part of his head and
i shot him
where was melody at the time you got up
the stairs
at the time i didn't know but she was on
in front of jimmy
on the floor with and he had the gun
pointed at her head okay
so you saw that yes okay did you hear
him saying anything to melody no
okay did you hear anything else no
when you got up the stairs
what made you feel at that point it was
necessary to shoot
i'm really not sure okay did you
hear anything that would have made you
think that your life was in danger
i heard your safety on his gun go click
off
okay well that's a really important
detail that i think we need to explore
so when you got upstairs
you heard a safety click off
dickson says he used a sled for moving
deer after hunting
to bring the body outside and waited
until he thought the coast was clear
to begin the burn the way i took it out
i went and got to deer sled
rolled put him on like a shower curtain
in a
blanket rolled him over put this sled
over top of him and flipped him on it
and drug him out
it wasn't impossible or trying have been
possible yes it was hard
but it wasn't impossible like detective
providence said
why would you burn the body afterward
i wasn't thinking about it all i was
thinking about was try to cover it up
i was on meth and you understand that
by trying to cover it up that's led to a
litany of other charges correct yes
you said you were on meth i understand
use of drugs is not an excuse for your
behavior right no
it's not okay are you just simply
explaining
yep about how long did it take for this
to burn
i burnt the fire probably 10-15 days
for quite a while yes and you heard the
testimony from the anthropologist that
some of the bones looked as if they'd
been cut
do you remember that yes did you cut any
part of the body up
no you did not no okay
so when you brought it out to the fire
pit you brought it out
just as it was yep the whole body
here this one last time is adam and
terry adam sometimes a defendant takes a
stand because
their testimony is the entire case other
times it's a hail mary against a strong
prosecution case
which one do you think it was here i
think it's the entire case
i think this is a very interesting
defense i think it's a good one
and when you have to take yourself out
of the mindset of what would a normal
person do
and he's saying wait wait wait put
yourself in the mindset
of where i was at on math uh i think it
can all of a sudden look a lot more
logical
and i think it's i think it's very
interesting i i
i have no idea which way this one's
gonna go but i could absolutely see him
being acquitted of murder
all right so adam thinks there's some
reasonable doubt there terry do you
think dixon's testimony created any
reasonable doubt
in this case i think it created some
doubt i don't think it created
reasonable doubt
and here's why he tried to cover up
this killing and he took the body he
chopped it he
burned it he tried to bury it i mean
there's just so much in its
consciousness
of guilt yes he can have a claim for
self-defense but
when you try to cover it up i think it
makes it far
more difficult for the jury to think
that you are innocent so
i don't think at the end of the day he's
going to get an acquittal i think we'll
see that this is a guilty verdict
yeah of course there's different charges
there i think he's trying to aim to beat
the top count there
and admit to the lower ones so we'll see
how it goes terry adam thank you for
joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
you